the emergencies on 911 get very creative
so how is season six going it's going
pretty well I mean we got one that's
coming up you know you know a lot of
people believe in coincidences and and
curses and stuff like that so that's a
real fun one oh I like coming up and
what do you do like superstitious yeah
yeah I personally don't believe in
coincidence that you don't you know I
love that saying you know it's it's too
coincidental not to be intentional oh
I've never heard that put that on a
bumper sticker I've never heard that
well after six seasons it's incredible
the writer is coming up with all these
different things that you're going
through that's incredible first of all
but do you feel like you're more
prepared for a real life emergency after
doing the show for six seasons
absolutely positively not what I know I
feel like that's a bit of a failure I'm
still scary we've had you know
especially when we get around that
Halloween season and all of that I don't
like Halloween I don't like I don't like
movies I don't like to be I don't like
scary movies but I like dressing up I
like a costume party okay yeah okay no
that's all I'm into I don't like like
horror things or like you know haunted
what are the houses you go nah that's
not like mad at you people pay people
for people to run after them with an ax
I'm like what's up are you out of your
mind yeah I don't get that either yeah I
make the biggest fool yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]